let's talk about the politics here now
so we got the story from the courier
journal senator rand paul claims
vindication
fund raises off of new anthony fauci
emails
rand paul questioned fauci and said what
do you ask about do you support the gate
like do you still support he said does
were you conducting gain of function
research i thought i thought he said
like do you still support
right and then fauci is like that is
senator that is incorrect entirely and
completely and completely incorrect
with no gain of function research was
done uh that's not true well and this
that's that whole interchange is amazing
because if you go back and watch it
it's he denies that it ever took place
he so he denies any of this funding in
wuhan so rand paul pushes him a little
bit more on it and then he starts
defending why they funded experiments in
muhammad so in the same exchange to be
fair i think it's self-evident that he
was lying
and i i wonder if when dashik the
ecohave alliance guy
is you know talking to him on the phone
or whatever the communications they were
having outside of email he's like this
is really bad that we're you know our
research may have caused this we need to
get in control of this
so fauci goes on tv and what dispels the
myth they say right and you look at how
early right you look at how early those
emails are you look at how early that
conversation is was it february yeah
march this is like the very start and
we're told dismiss not a thing don't
worry about it washington post is is
running headlines debunk debunk debunk
why is debunked because about you said
so so so i'll say you know because i
take i take the the more hyperbolic
stance of saying it proves fouchy lied
these emails because in my opinion i
think thatch is playing semantics yeah i
think i think he he he's playing
semantics to try and get around the fact
that he he lied to rand paul
under oath many people are saying it was
perjury and when he dismissed gain of
function research even though the people
he sent the in the article to we're like
oh yeah it looks engineered so he's
lying
i think on top of this
fauci was probably sweating bullets
you hear news about this this covet
thing and he's probably going like
who did we fund and then he calls
ecohealth alliance and he's like what
did you guys do you okay you've got to
find that that email from his assistant
then because that's what they say that
that do we have some
link some distance link that's the
phraseology they use distant link to
this work abroad so it's like they do
everything they can to not use the word
wuhan or wuhan institute of virology
but it seems like they know that there
is an issue going on here and by the way
this whole thing i i should mention this
right you know talking about emails and
foia this is why hillary had set up that
server right because she knew that foyo
get you foil get you if you're a little
loose loosey-goosey with that stuff and
apparently that's what was going on here
in my opinion
that email shows it fauci was probably
you know pulling us collar going like oh
man if this was one of our programs and
how many people died millions it was
like three something million three and a
half three and a half million oh yeah
and that's because he funded this
research now
you're they're not going to blame him
directly because he provided funding to
an organization who provided funding to
a wuhan lab
but it's still this is this is the you
know the classic michael crichton um
you know phromology of it where
you know you you
you only focused i'm gonna butcher the
line but you know you only focused on
what you could do and you never thought
about whether or not you should right
yeah yeah yeah yeah so fauci
uh uh and he has that op-ed now that
that's coming out i think it's from 2012
where he was asked about that oh yes
they pulled it out right the dangers of
gain of function research and what did
he say is that even if it does escape
the lab and cause some it's worth the
risk it's worth the risk it's worth the
risk and so this is what gets me back to
my my initial statement though my thesis
is where are these emails and it's
possible that this was on a different
you know okay those were you know maybe
that was classified maybe that was done
on a higher server because of
communication there's all sorts of
reasons that stuffing might would be
classified right and that it wouldn't
show up in foia um i was never nih so i
don't know whether or not they operate
under a classified system but i
understand that if you know obviously if
something is at a secret level or a ts
level it's not going to be coming out in
the foia that being said um
he easily could have come out and said
yeah we were looking into this and oh by
the way here are the top 10 things we
found in wuhan that are similar to this
this is just like that study that oh
sure jung lee the batwoman and she came
up with this study from a year ago that
these spike proteins that's exactly what
we looked at and here's you know here's
this plan on the shelf see the idea
behind all of this or at least sort of
the you know the raise on debt was that
there would be
an on-the-shelf plan or game plan for
okay we we've this is the one that's
crossed over to the human population
this is the coronavirus that made it it
was this variant so we've studied it we
have an understanding of how it works
these are the best things to use against
it right that was the entire point
where is that work where is any of that
after a decade
what were they doing what did they what
did they ultimately develop and it seems
to be a whole lot of nothing
and it comes up in ventilators and
remember the ventilators are the big
thing and then matt damasks work do they
not work he tells someone they don't
work then he comes out saying that well
we should anyway because of you know the
percentages in terms of the population
and so
you're looking at this going well wait
you know just just based on what you're
saying you know the whole point of
funding wuhan the 2012 op-ed was that we
would have some
you know early warning system in place
i pulled up the article so it was a it
was a 2011 article i believe the new
york post reports fauci once argued for
risky viral experiments even if they can
lead to a pandemic and now the article
from washington post it's uh it's
actually
you search for google and it pops up
because so many people are clicking on
it but i want to make one point i've
made a couple times in the past couple
of weeks
initially fauci said don't wear masks
and he does this interview on 16 minutes
came out in march and he was like
masks are for people who are infected to
stop them from infecting others
right now people should not be wearing
masks it might stop a droplet but you
know
we don't you shouldn't be walking around
and then in the email that everyone's
sharing it's from february he says
basically the same thing to someone who
asked for advice here's the problem with
this
thought she comes out in july and says
i said that because we knew our medical
professionals needed the ppe because
they're the ones who have to deal with
sick people
but fauci said masks don't protect you
from sick people
so what why would the medical
professionals need it they're not gonna
get the sick person sick and it's not
gonna prevent them from getting sick but
medical professionals still need them i
guess in general okay fine that's fair
but if people
it's it's like why does the x-ray
technician stand behind the thing
because they're the ones there all day
right right so you have doctors with the
masks because they're treating the sick
people
did fauci not consider that if people
wore masks they wouldn't spread the
virus and then the doctors wouldn't need
as many masks because they wouldn't be
working long hours with sick people you
see you see the problem here is either
fauci is a a real [ __ ]
because he doesn't understand cause and
effect we'll tell everybody not to wear
masks
because we and he says on 60 minutes the
mask will stop an infected person from
affecting others then he tells everyone
don't wear the masks because the doctors
need them to treat you when you get sick
because no one was wearing masks
meanwhile the the spread is continuing
throughout the population which means
that a higher percentage of doctors of
course is going to need them so it is
this sort of interesting thing
where you get into and you know thomas
rates about this where there are certain
people who it seems that when they when
they think about problems they take out
that human element yes right that
element of human nature that element of
like this you could get into a whole
like liberal conservative kind of thing
about this where you know look i
i would love to live in this world where
it's it's just it's utopia and everybody
shares things but human nature is real
and you can't get away from that and you
know this this genius
is why fauci commands what like four
hundred and thirty thousand dollars a
year from the federal government it is
yeah well trump was giving away a salary
but uh this the president gets four
hundred thousand i actually made more
than the last president there you go
like everyone with last president
yeah cause he was getting yeah was it
giving himself a dollar i think i think
he legally had to yeah like do one he
would donate whatever and then he would
still donate that dollar yeah yeah
so uh
for all of this for all of this genius
i thought she gets all that money
so i saw you tweet you said you said
that they're uh actively planning an
exit for the guy yeah so i got a message
um late last night and of course i was
up watching uh batman cartoons of course
uh which very which batman actually
batman versus robin so i'm getting into
like the old like the standalone movie
series that came out um i guess from
like the 2015 era and now that i've
brought the suspense up let's go back to
flight i know right yeah so
batman was actually really good i like
totally got sucked in i hadn't watched
it and then it was on my plaque so i was
like oh check this out and it's like
really and my kid didn't like it cause
it's like it's like much more adult
everyone's on the edge of their seats
right now going just i know
it's going super viral so
but but basically they said look
because the emails came out from
buzzfeed right
they can't put it in that sort of bucket
of oh that's conservative media right
it came out from buzzfeed then
washington post apparently had a similar
foia so they came out as well and so it
had to be something that they responded
to
and one of the first things no obviously
they're talking about multiple angles on
this but they're saying you know what
maybe since this thing is winding down
we can look at a potential exit strategy
he's got a book for the good doctor does
he have a book though does he because
so we saw that faulty essentially this
announcement came out about a fouchy
book but then i went on amazon late earl
uh later this afternoon and the listing
was gone totally going well people were
saying you know is he is he profiting
from the pandemic this seems unseemly
they were making comparisons to andrew
cuomo so not you know so it's like you
know it's like woke down play the virus
uh you know a broke down play the virus
woke fun fun wuhan bespoke put the
actual uh you know infected patients in
the nursing home yeah so that's so
that's cuomo he's easy next level so you
know i don't know if it's that i don't
know it could it could also be a legal
thing right he's still a federal
employee but it does definitely seem
like there's something going on and that
his his tenure may be maybe coming to an
early did you see how buzzfeed framed
the emails
how how fouchy was trying to keep things
together at a time of chaos my favorite
is my favorite is cnn yes it's
enthusiastic just it's it's a complete
ideography it's it's we're not going to
discuss anything that's actually in the
emails but you know the fact that he was
able to respond to so many emails while
he was so busy there he is dr fauci
exhausted late into the night responding
to email after email honesty just
wonderful
and then i'm like why didn't they frame
it like the new york posted like early
emails suggest fauci knew the potential
for
uh
lab leak
covet engine it was being engineered
because it feels like cnn is sort of the
last legacy media outlet that is really
on this sort of fouchy train that you
know not only
you know not only because it's like
this is a government employee right he's
a bureaucrat he's a he's a leader we
should be skeptical of all right
government employees and government
officials but you know we don't need to
hold them up as some sort of you know
paragon of of wisdom and you know the
oracle at delphi or something like this
you know it's it's he's a government guy
so but cnn is still on that train
they're still trying to sell the fouchy
merch even still trying to do all this
and even buzzfeed is turned i'm thinking
to myself why would they publish any
emails at all because they many of them
make them look bad and then try and
frame the story as a positive not to
mention the implications of mark
zuckerberg so zuckerberg's emails are
interesting and i you know and this is
kind of
from a lot of the peter dashak stuff was
actually kind of out there already so me
looking at it was like well you know we
kind of knew this but it is nice to have
that confirmation because again it
becomes one of those things and you know
it's sort of the journalistic game of
you know it's not what you know but it's
what you can prove in court so the fact
that you have the emails now where they
are discussing gain of function huge
huge monumental right just in terms of
newsworthiness but in terms of the
overall story it just kind of fills in
those gaps so that we basically all
suspected to begin with but the
zuckerberg stuff is super interesting to
me because when you when you look at
the whole situation of not just
zuckerberg and fouchy right but you look
at zuckerberg from his perch
throughout 2020 right and so there he is
talking to fauci
in the beginning of 2020 hey how can we
help how can we i i do think he he
probably meant that in you know from
coming from a good place i do want like
he does want to help you know so he goes
to fouchy and val she's telling him oh
we need the social distancing and then
eventually it becomes the lockdowns and
facebook is pushing those
and then later on when the lockdowns are
coming oh we're locked down how are we
going to have an election and who is it
that comes in and so many people have
reported on this that it's it's these
foundations that are then set up and
funded by zuckerberg chan to help with
the election in many of these cities and
many of these
typically trending blue areas also
zuckerberg and it's kind of one of those
things where you really look back and we
say do we as a society
want any one person right the william
randolph-hearst is a great example on
one unelected person to have that level
of influence in our country
no
especially with hurst it's pretty
obvious what he did with to marijuana
and his tree paper mill industry i don't
know if you're much familiar with hearst
but he's like a paper magnet on all
these newspapers decided he didn't like
the competition of people growing him
hemp and making like parchment out of
hemp so he started printing all this
propaganda about why hemp was so
dangerous and driving people insane and
used his propaganda paper to and
zuckerberg is doing the modern version
of this where you go on facebook and you
say these opinions aren't allowed these
opinions are and then you hire and end
it full circle what were those opinions
a year ago
oh you could you could you couldn't talk
about lab leaks you couldn't talk about
lab yeah i mean there's still a lot of
stuff you can't say i don't even know if
i'm sitting here waiting like youtube
will eventually ban us i guess steven
crowder was talking about cdc
uh uh numbers and youtube gave him a
strike
he got it i hadn't heard that really
yeah stephen crowder's been off youtube
for two weeks because they were talking
about cdc guidelines no no i think that
was the first one okay they're they
they've got they had a warning before he
got a strike then he got uh he got a
warning then he got a strike over the
cdc and then the second strike i think
was because they were saying that the
police were justified in the shooting of
mikaya bryant and youtube was like you
were celebrating it so then they had
taken off but the first strike when he
mentioned that he was talking about cdc
guidelines and he said some specifics i
don't want to put words in his mouth but
he was basically just saying like here's
what cdc says here's what we think
youtube game is strikeforce and so to
your point this this is the problem
right this is the problem with allowing
the social media platforms to be
arbiters of truth because they become
arbiters of discussion and at the same
time going back to the foias now that we
see the fauchy leaks now that we see the
emails in there he's having the exact
same discussions internally that people
were trying to have on social media zero
hedge of course was sort of the canary
in the coal mine of this because they're
the one of one of the very first places
that was publicly talking about the
wuhan lab they were zapped permabanned
on twitter for this now they were
reinstated but when that first came out
that sent eight people don't talk about
the repercussions oh that was just your
hedge no no what were the repercussions
of that what was the secondary and
tertiary effects everyone was basically
told the message was sent this topic is
verboten you are not speaking about this
this is like talking this week is the
tangent square anniversary
of the massacre june 4th so it's like
talking about tiananmen square in china
right it if this is done you will be
disappeared that's the message it's sent
to everybody that's the freakiest thing
about cancer culture is not only is it
top-down authoritarian you're banned but
it's that people become afraid of even
mentioning it so it's like the
grassroots effect of cancer you know
just like canceling yourself before you
even begin well if you talk to people
who who are from the soviet union my
wife is from the soviet union she was
born there um
you you realize that because you don't
know where the rules are you don't know
where the fault lines are you don't know
where like the ideological landmines are
you know am i supposed to like this
person or hate this person that kind of
stuff the only way to really be safe is
to not have opinions right is to not
question anything not have opinions on
things it's to shut down in a very
internalized way so the the overall
you know the final end state of cancel
culture is that you're canceling your
own mind you're canceling your own
opinions you're cancering your
individuality
um and that's and it's internal the
sensor is actually in you don't need you
know the ministry of truth because
that's just in your head every day
that really disturbed that really
disturbs me because then they're
removing themselves it doesn't have to
be the government it doesn't have to be
facebook it doesn't have to be i'm not
saying by the way i'm not saying tanya
is like that you know right
she's been america or she uh she she she
makes she makes her opinions known
often remember that photo from uh uh it
was a soviet union and there's like
stalin he's on a boat
next to him yeah but then like all of a
sudden there's another photo and there's
like no guy next to him what was that
called they have a name for that or a
word for what they were doing with
history so airbrushing know back in the
day yeah airbrushing but you know what
they call it airbrushing one thing one
thing it reminds me of something i i
heard from a north korean defector once
who was talking about this situation and
he said
you know and it's it's not as uh it's
not as nice as the way sultanaton would
put it but you know the defector said
look
we know that they're lying about the
united states we know that they're lying
about the western world like we know
that you're not just killing each other
all the time and it's like
race war and racial strife constantly we
know it's not like that right and and
this chaotic situation but the problem
is because of the censorship we don't
know what the truth is yeah so we don't
know what it actually is like so because
we have no we have nothing to verify it
on we have nothing to compare it to
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you